Why do spiral galaxies have arms?
Is it to hug us?
Hello star citizens, Trace for DNews.
When you think of the Milky way, you probably
picture that familiar spiral shape we’ve
all come to know and love.
That spiral structure is very common for galaxies
- over three quarters of the one’s we’ve
observed are in this pinwheel shape - and
our own galaxy is actually in a subgroup called
barred spiral galaxies.
But how exactly spiral galaxies get their
shape is still up for debate.
Most galaxies spin around a central point,
usually a supermassive black hole.
It’s tempting to think that those spiral
arms are practically solid structures, with
the same stars all sticking together as they
revolve around the center of the galaxy.
If that were true, that would mean that the
stars on the tips of the arms have to move
faster than the stars near the center to keep
up.
This doesn’t jive well with the laws of
physics.
In reality, objects move faster when they’re
closer to the point they’re orbiting around,
otherwise they’d lose the battle with gravity
and get sucked in.
This is Kepler’s third law, and it’s why
Earth’s orbit takes a year while Mercury’s
is just 88 days.
This means though that if the arms were made
up of the same stars, then as the galaxy rotates,
the arms would get stretched out and wound
up like they were in a cosmic taffy machine.
Our sun takes around 250 million years to
do a lap of the galaxy, which sounds like
a long time but on an astronomical timescale
is pretty quick.
At those speeds spiral galaxies should wind
their arms into oblivion before any appreciable
length of time, and we shouldn’t be observing
as many of these galaxies as we do.
Astronomers call this the wind-up problem,
and they’ve come up with two explanations
for the arms.
One is that the arms aren’t material, but
are actually the product of a density wave.
As stars travel around the galaxy, they’ll
come to areas where they’ll bunch up for
a while and then areas where they’re more
spread out.
This means that even though the stars are
moving inside the arms, the arms themselves
look pretty stationary.14 You can think of
it like a traffic jam: from afar the jam appears
to stay in one place on the highway, but the
cars that make up that jam are actually flowing
through it.
What would cause these density waves in the
first place is still hotly debated.
Astronomers have found that spiral arms could
be caused by other nearby galaxies, or driven
by the large bar shape at the center of some
galaxies.
But bars and companion galaxies are not universal,
so explaining galaxies that have neither with
the density wave model is tricky.
The other popular explanation is Stochastic
Self-Propagating Star Formation, but its friends
call it SSPSF.
The basic idea behind it is: star formation
in a galaxy, causes a shock wave, that kicks
off more star formation.
The rotation of the galaxy stretches the bright
new stars into the familiar spiral arms, and
they burn out and die as the chain reaction
propagates and the arms move on.
It’s possible SSPSF and the density wave
model actually work together, and stars are
formed in the denser areas, making the arms
look brighter with their hot new stars.
So those are the most accepted explanations
of spiral formation, but confirming them can
only be answered after hundreds of millions
of years of observation.
So if you’re looking for a career with job
security, might I suggest astronomy?
For a long time we thought we were the only
galaxy, and then we found Andromeda.
If you want to know more about our galactic
neighbor, check out Julia’s video here.
Space is a big topic and there are lots of
questions to explore.
Let us know your space questions!